Okay Michael so this wraps up all this
Bayesian Learning stuff. What have we learned today?
>> We did Bayes rule.
>> We learned Bayes rule. We even learned how to derive Bayes rule.
>> And it was super useful because it
let's you swap, kind of, causes and effect.
>> So I like the way you put that, Michael that
we're swapping causes and effects. Sort of mathematically when we think about
Bayes rule, what that really let's us do is. Instead of
having to compute the probably of a hypothesis given the data We
instead view to compute the probability of the
data given the hypothesis, which is typically a
much easier thing to do. And what makes it of course Bayes rule in general is
that you weight that by the prior probability
over the hypothesis. Which in fact is one
of the important things that we learned which
is that priors matter. So anything else we learned?
>> Yep, we did the MAP hypothesis, Maximum a posteriori. Right.
We learned about HMap, and we also learned about HML.
>> ML, right. The maximum likelihood hypothesis. > Right. And what's the
maximum likelihood hypothesis? How's it relate
to the maximum a posteriori hypothesis?
>> It's the MAP that you get when the prior is uniform.
>> Right. Alright. And we, oh, we
connected up maximum a posteriori and least squares.
>> Yeah, that was pretty, I really liked that. So, we basically der, we
deroved. We derived a bunch of things we'd
been doing before. And short of showed that
there's actually a good argument for them. At
least if you're Bayesian. There are good arguments for
doing some doing sum of squares. There are good
arguments for Occam's Razor. We'd actually be able
to give real justification for doing them other
than, well sure it makes us one of them.
>> Right so that includes the minimum description length story.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And then finally,
you told me that was all a lie, and you said that really what you want to do
is this other kind of way of picking that
actually factors in the probability of all the different hypotheses
and having them essentially vote. Right. What we really
care about, is classification. We're learning in the end and
so we also learned about Bayes classifiers. So in
fact, what we described before, which is voting of hypothesis.
Turns out to be the Bayes optimal classifier. I
didn't say that, but it is very important to note.
In fact, what you should be noting there is
not only is it the Bayes optimal classifier, it's the
Bayes optimal classifier. And what that means is that
on average you cannot do any better than basically doing
a weighted vote of all the hypotheses according to
the probability of the hypothesis given the data. You cannot
do any better than this on average. So
again, what Bayesian learning gives us and what Bayesian
classification gives us is a way of talking
about optimality and gold standards. What'd you think, Michael?
>> That's really neat.
>> I like it. I mean, I have to tell
you, I really think that this stuff is kind of cool.
It's always nice to be able to take things that actually
work and explain them according to some framework, some underlying theory.
>> I wonder though, it seems like
all these Bayesian equations lead us to the question, of how we actually infere
probabilities from various different quantities and observations.
So is there a way to do that?
>> So I think the answer is yes. And maybe you should
go figure it out and then tell me about it next time.
>> Okay. [LAUGH] All right, as you wish.
>> As you wish.
>> Stay tuned.
>> Anyway, this has been a lot of fun, Michael.
I will talk to you later.
>> Thanks.
>> Bye.